and to chart our progress and to avoid  going back to square one we're  establishing a new co vide alert system  run by a new joint biosecurity Center  and that co vid alert level will be  determined primarily by our and the  number of coronavirus cases and in turn  that kobe the alert level will tell us  how tough we have to be in our social  distancing measures the lower the level  the few of the measures the higher the  level the tougher and stricter we will  have to be there will be five alert  levels level one means the disease is no  longer present in the UK and level five  is the most critical the kind of  situation we could have had if the NHS  had been overwhelmed over the period of  the lockdown we've been in level four  and it's thanks to your sacrifice were  now in a position to begin to move in  steps to level three and as we go  everyone will have a role to play in  keeping the order